فهو رئيس يلعب دورا اساسيا بالشراكه مع
الكونجرس في حمايه وتحصين العلاقات التي
تجمع الولايات المتحده مع تايوان في هذه
الاوقات التي نشهدوا فيها تغيرا في
الدبلوماسيه
كانت هناك تاكيدات من الرئيس ريجن سابقا
بان بموجب قانون تايوان الذي تمت مصادقته
من قبل كونجرس وساهمت لوضع اللبنى
الاساسيه لهذه العلاقه التي جمعتنا لعقود
من الزمن حافظنا خلال تلك الفتره على
استطباب سلامي والازدهار
وارسائل الديمقراطيه في تايوان
لكن لم يعد خافيا عليكم اليوم ان السلام
الذي تنعمنا به هو الديمقراطيه التي عملنا
بجد من اجل الحصول عليها
يواجهان تحديات غير مسبوقه
مره اخرى نجد انفسنا في عالم حال
الديمقراطيه الاخرى موضعه تهديد
ومساله الحفاظ على
مكانتنا كمناره للديمقراطيه تتعرض متى
تتعرض للتهديدات قال الرئيس ما يلي الحريه
هي ليست نموذج
لجيل واحد وبعدها تنقرض يجب ان تكون ابديه
ولابد من الدفاع عنها بصوره مستمره من قبل
كافه الاجيال
من خلال المناقشات مع زعماء الكونغرس هذا
الصباح دعوني اكرر التزامي تايوان في
الدفاع عن الوضع السلمي الحالي حيث ان
الشعب التايواني سوف يعمل على العمل
لتحقيق مجتمع منفتح وحر وكذلك شددته في
حديث
الى ما ذكره
الرئيس ريجن في مقوله بانه من اجل الحفاظ
على السلم لابد لنا ان نكون اقوياء وهنا
اود ان اضيف باننا سوف نكون اكثر قوه
عندما نكون معا
ومن هذا المنطلق لابد لان اعبر عن امتنان
نيابه عن الشعب التايواني لاعضاء الكونجرس
في الموجودين في هذه القاعه والذين
شاركونا في الحوار من الحزبين هناك جمله
من المبادرات التي تم طرحها من اجل جعل
ومبادرتنا اكثر قوه ولا سيما تلك المبادره
المتعلقه بتعزيز قدرات الدفاع الجوي في
تايوان
وهي جزء من الروابط الاقتصاديه التي
تجمعنا ودعم في دعم
ومشاركتها في الاسره الدوليه لابد لي ايضا
ان اعبر عن اهتمامنا في تحقيق السلام
والازدهار في منطقه المحيط الهادي
تسعى
لتكون شريكا يوثق به من قبل العالم ومقرا
للاستقرار في تلك المنطقه وبكل تاكيد
ابعد من ذلك في الختام
هناك
مقوله دائما لا نسمعها باننا لن نكون
لوحدنا وفي سياق مساعينا لحمايه طريقه
حياتنا فاننا متاكدون بان الولايات
المتحده سوف تكون معنا في ظل مواجهه هذه
التحديات الغريبه والفريده من نوعها في
هذا الزمن لابد لنا ان نتذكر المبادئ التي
شكلت هذه الشراكه العظيمه متذكرين الدروس
التي رسمها الرئيس ريجان من خلال تركته
الكبيره مره اخرى شكرا
رئيس المجلس مكارتي على صداقاتكم واود ان
اشكر كافه اصدقائي في الكونجرس للوقوف مع
تايوان شكرا جزيلا